it's great to welcome to the program
today Benjamin Studebaker who is a PhD
student at the University of Cambridge
also the author of a very interesting
article I don't remember how I found
recently but I did find it called the
decline and fall of Elizabeth Warren
which I read I think while on the
treadmill at my gym Benjamin and and
even in that circumstance it still fully
captivated my my attention I was I was
able to stay on the treadmill
fortunately so let's talk about I mean I
I think that the context now of course
to think about Elizabeth Warren is in
the context of the 2020 primary and her
declaration that she is I guess it's
it's not yet a formal announcement but
she's going to be exploring and every
indication is that she is indeed running
when you talk about her decline and fall
are we talking about politics are we
talking about electability are we
talking about the DNA fiasco what did
you mean by that yeah so I think in
about 2014 Elizabeth Warren was seen as
the leader of the left faction of the
Democratic Party and is the only person
who was even vaguely left-wing who might
get any kind of political traction in
American politics and I think that that
began to shift going into 2015
when she declined to challenge Hillary
Clinton then when she declined to
endorse Bernie Sanders before the
Massachusetts primary and then when she
kind of got outflanked on a number of
policy areas by Bernie Sanders over the
preceding couple of years and I think
she's had a hard time regaining her
standing with the left of the party
which has now moved a bit to the left of
where she was at yeah I actually got a
phone call from an audience member last
week saying why do I think that there
are some so-called progressives within
the Democratic Party that are sort of
shunning Elizabeth Warren and I think
some of the things you mentioned are
definitely factors the non endorsement
of Bernie Sanders during the primary is
something people are talking about the
the possible kind of tactical mistake
around the DNA test keeps coming up and
I'm glad to sort of hear your thoughts
about whether you think that that's a
factor but in the end I mean she does
have this this
sort of admittedly kind of amorphous
credential as the second most
progressive senator in the Senate right
now
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
accomplishment is one that I think in
the context of vulture capitalism and
everything that the left is learning
about our economic system I think that
that is also a strong credential and I
actually think that the fact that she
has not adopted the term Democratic
Socialist I consider that a good thing
because there are some Democrats who
have incorrectly adopted that term
without seemingly understanding that
they're actually Social Democrats not
democratic socialists so I think that
some of the points you make are good but
I questioned whether some of them are
actually features rather than bugs hmm
so I think that one of the things I've
noticed with her is that she for
instance on health care initially before
Obama became president she had health
care proposals that were not as far left
as the ACA and then after the ACA came
in then she came up with proposals that
were a little bit to the left of where
the ACA was and then Bernie Sanders came
out with Medicare for all and then she
responded to that by saying that she was
for Medicare for all and then she
started putting out white papers for
stuff that's ACA plus a little extra
and she's released a white paper for ACA
plus little extra after having come out
for Medicare for all right well this
okay I'm glad you bring that up because
we've been talking more and more about
is Medicare for all the new litmus test
for 2020 and my prediction has been and
it's starting to sort of be borne out
that in some general sense it is a
litmus test where you're going to have
to say I believe Medicare for all or
something like it is the end goal to
which we should aspire but that you're
going to see some Democrats kind of
playing coy with it by saying yeah I
think that that is the end point but
here's what I would actually propose
doing in the interim and they'll
probably cite a sort of pragmatic
justification for that it that's what
you're saying Elizabeth Warren is doing
it sounds like yeah and so she will
position herself often as having the
same end policy goals but
her substantive proposals won't be as
radical for instance she tends to be for
debt forgiveness on the student debt
issue rather than tuition free college
yes so I think I think those are things
that if you're a hardcore Bernie Kratt
from 2016 you're looking at that and
going that isn't maybe quite as radical
as I would like to see and that I think
that you also have this issue that and I
want to get to the Native American thing
in a second but you also have this issue
where there's a perception that I I
think that she isn't willing to fight
for the left in the party and that she
wants to work with the party where it is
rather than make the party into
something different
so whereas Bernie Sanders seems to think
it's important to challenge Democratic
centrists with progressive or left-wing
primary opponents and try to beat them
in primaries Elizabeth Warren because
she didn't run against Hillary Clinton
and because she didn't endorse Sanders
during the campaign and because she
doesn't have the same traction with the
under 30s doesn't seem like the kind of
person who can lead a prolonged campaign
within the party to move the party to
the left and if you think that a lot of
these policy proposals or policy
proposals that many Democrats are not
currently willing to support the
question is how will we get Democrats
who are willing to support that and I
don't think it's a given that those
Democrats will support it if you get a
progressive who's elected president in
much the same way that it hasn't been a
given that Republicans would support
repealing and replacing Obamacare simply
because Donald Trump is president many
of them said over and over that they
supported those things and then when
they became president they bailed on him
yeah I mean it sort of seems like maybe
I'm overly pragmatic but the way I've
described it before is that Bernie
Sanders deep down historically liked
going back to the 70s kind of came out
of the hip hips hipster hippie at the
time I guess actually close to socialist
movement and has moved to the right in
terms of what his publicly stated
proposals are Elizabeth Warren on the
other hand came from the more regulated
capita
law professor more more sort of
establishment point and moved to the
left as you're describing and as I've
described to end up somewhere that's
slightly to the right of Bernie but I
still in my mind believe that if if
Bernie runs I'm probably supporting
Bernie but if Elizabeth Warren were to
defeat him I find it to be a pretty okay
compromise and I would I would not have
a problem supporting her I think that
they come from different places but
they've ended up in relatively similar
positions on a lot of issues although
admittedly couched in very different
economic ideas hmm I think from a policy
standpoint they're both trying to take
relatively similar policy positions but
where I would really differentiate them
is in their attitude and approach to our
institutions yes I think for Bernie
Sanders the Democratic Party is not in
an okay place it's not currently a party
which can advance the set of policies
that he wants to see and so for Bernie
it's not just a matter of being for
these policies it's also for changing
and reforming the Democratic Party into
the kind of institution that can
effectively pursue them whereas I think
Elizabeth Warren's strategy has been to
work with the center of the party
pragmatically to try to find compromises
that the center of the party can live
with the question is will the center of
the party ever support the more radical
staff yeah I I think I agree with you on
that and I think that in the the idea of
it's the difference between uh pending
the systems versus improving them
slightly is the way I think we would
kind of sum it up let's talk about the
DNA thing so do you think that in terms
of a 2020 candidacy the release of
Elizabeth Warren's DNA results related
to her purported Native American
ancestry ah reliability is it a
non-factor does it help so I think it's
it's a liability the question is
precisely what kinds so I think the the
incident in itself isn't so bad it has
two negative features one is that Native
Americans of course
don't believe that you can claim Native
American identity on the basis of blood
or ethnicity they don't have that kind
of self concept for them you have to
have tribal citizenship or identity and
so it's a political status identity
rather than an ethno identity so they're
upset about that and people who
sympathize with them will be upset about
that on the other side Trump of course
will make a lot of hay out of it and has
already used it to make those memes
where it's Elizabeth Warren one xx xx
instead of 2020 he's gonna do that
anyway but what I think is more
concerning than those immediate optical
issues is what it says about her
judgment in a campaign in terms of how
she would respond to Trump's attacks I
think that she's someone that I've
observed over the last two years
takes his bait and gives him the kind of
response that he wants more than other
Democrats and I remember seeing her
respond to one of his disposal Ana's
taunts with a tweet storm that was 15
tweets long and any one of those tweets
might have been fine in a vacuum but to
have 15 tweets in 15 minutes that's the
kind of response where if I'm online and
I see someone do that I go oh that guy
got to that person yeah I am I mean so I
I've made it a goal to at least at this
early stage of the primary not play what
I call lect ability games which include
sort of assessments of what might happen
if Trump tweets about this person what
might happen if they get on a general
election debate stage because I think
that if we learned anything from the
Republican primary in 2016 it's that
playing the electability games and the
hypothetical games rather than just
focusing on whose politics do I agree
with most is not a great strategy for
Democrats but it's very hard to deny
that she does not seem particularly
adept at handling the types of attacks
you're talking about it's very hard for
me to make a strong case against that
yeah and I don't think that people
should be picking a candidate it's
solely on the basis of electability but
I think that if we can't find someone
who seems to be able to handle the
day-to-day
punches in a way that is clever and has
a substantive politics that's
interesting and persuasive and exciting
that that would be a good thing so of
the people who have announced so far who
do you think that is oh I have a lot of
doubts about a lot of the people running
and it's difficult because and it's sort
of unfair because each one of these
people to move up in the Democratic
Party had to come up at a time when the
Democratic Party was increasingly
dependent on banks for money and when it
was increasingly committed to a
tough-on-crime posturing and because of
this it's hard for people who came up in
the 90s in that generation acts to have
consistently throughout their careers
demonstrated of politics that I can have
full confidence in but I know that some
of those people were doing that for
political reasons and some of them were
doing it because they really believed in
it and it's very hard to differentiate
who is who simply in terms of the so now
we're going fully into how they would
handle a race against Trump and not into
policy at all to be very clear of people
who have announced and who might
announce
I mean who strikes you as the person
that would be most sort of temperamental
e-fit and have the type of talent that
is required to refute the the dynamic
that Donald Trump creates with the
nicknames and the physical attacks on
physical appearance and all of that
stuff I think the unfortunate answer to
that and it gives me no pleasure to say
this is that the the white male
candidates are harder for him to pick on
in the way that he conventionally picks
on people and particularly people who
are of his generation and close to him
in age so now interesting that the
question is obviously Biden would be one
of those people yeah Bernie one of those
people I mean because he seems to have
done okay with the attacks on Bernie
Bernie of course as a Jewish man is in
in a sense of course he is white in
another sense he's also not white so
where does that figure it yeah Bernie I
I think it is interesting because
Bernie's entire style is to constantly
two issues and constantly talk issues
over and over again when you go to a
Bernie stump speech it's he says this is
a terrible problem in the country and
here's the thing we need to do and he
does that for every issue one after
another after another so I think that it
would be difficult because I don't see
Bernie Sanders being willing to engage
Trump in his style talk about the
personal and talk about himself and I
think that might to some degree blunt
Trump's attacks but also it would it
would be a kind of refusal to engage in
the banter rather than it's unclear
whether that would be a plus or a minus
in in a general election campaign but I
guess Bernie hasn't even announced yet
so maybe it's a question we can kind of
consider at some point in the future
we've been speaking with Benjamin
studebaker PhD student at the University
of Cambridge also author of the article
the decline and fall of Elizabeth Warren
which we will link to from our YouTube
channel Ben thank you so much for
talking to me today thanks for having me
it's been great